do you think the characters
in this movie have seen jurassic park
or do you think that it just doesn't
exist i don't think they exist
in this world every time that we write
about godzilla versus kong on collider
uh now there's a huge amount of interest
but all the commenters
on social and everywhere all ask why
don't they just kiss
so i'm just curious i'm curious if
director adam wingard
ever told you uh why godzilla and kong
don't just kiss in the movie
i don't know real question i feel like
there's a lot of tension there i could
see it
i there's tension there is tension it's
like boiling and it's waiting to happen
man that would be an awkward kiss too
can you imagine
i don't know if you could kiss godzilla
it'll like really rip
the like the edge of your lips and then
poor kong has like
really big lips so that like beak would
go away i don't know
i don't know if this could work actually
thank you that's that's that's great
um one of the things about this is that
as an actor
you're obviously you really got to use
your imagination when you're making a
movie like this because you're not going
to see the finished vfx
i'm sure you only saw the movie recently
so what was it what was it like for you
actually seeing the finished film
and seeing them fighting and all the vfx
it was insane i think that no matter how
much you play with your imagination you
never really have a clear sense of how
it's going to look like and that
is a testament to how incredible the vfx
on this team was you know
the way that they created this world you
i i definitely had an idea that it was
going to be it's spectacle and fun and
big and blah blah blah
but i didn't expect it to be this
beautiful it's a beautiful film it's
really
uh aesthetically pleasing i i felt like
the coloring and the world and the way
that they created them it really worked
out so
it's nothing i mean it definitely is a
quarter of what i thought it was gonna
like my imagination was a quarter of
what it really ended up being because it
is
absolutely mind-blowing
if you were not in this movie or even
being in this movie
who would you be rooting for a godzilla
or khan
um i would be rooting for kong i don't
know i feel like
i just have a in in
more connection just because the ape and
we come from the ape i feel like i have
a connection for that reason
but i would guess in my heart i would
think that someone like
godzilla would win because he looks a
little bit more meteor
and then he has the torch he has like
added on things that
kong doesn't so i would say godzilla but
you never know you have to watch the
movie to see who wins actually
completely for fans of this branch look
for fans of the monster genre
is there anything that really surprised
you about making the movie that perhaps
you weren't expecting
that you can kind of share yeah i guess
that
i didn't expect it to be that emotional
and
uh so humanized i didn't expect the
characters i feel like from the
experience of watching the last
few movies it wasn't that way it was
more um
sort of um a big show
and the other thing i didn't expect is
female characters being so
strong and independent i i'm we're used
to seeing the damsel in distress
situation in these films
and this in this film is completely the
opposite there's no female in distress
on the contrary there's such an add-on
and importance
to the film that it was really exciting
because it felt like it really feels
like an updated version of what the
world looks like now
i agree with that thank you so much for
your time good luck with the rest of
your speed dating
thank you so much love speed dating bye